I've been using my new right machine for a week now, no matter how much time is indicated for each night's session, the bulb is always active lights on some noise and hot temperature of bulb for 10 hours, rather than what is listed on each night's page is this normal.
Yes, no, so if you have the computer open after you hit run, often the frequencies will feed back to the computer and affect that timer, that timer as it's tiny down could be inaccurate.
That's why we suggest that you once you hit run, you close the computer so you have the computer go to sleep, you'll have less chance of it feeding back to that and stayed on longer and getting stuck in the last frequency.
You've had issues in the past where sometimes people will say, my ribs are always supposed to be eight hours and I got up in the morning and left with it still on and I came home and it was on all day long, what in the world is going on.
If you left the computer open, usually that's the reason because the frequencies, these are frequencies and they affect electronics sometimes so it could have been back to that person said I do close the computer but sometimes that right away so it could have just been back to that so just close the computer.
Also the time where it says on there and says eight hours that's not always correct so you could just ignore that if it's staying on for like 15 hours or something it's just getting stuck on the last frequency, there's no harm in it.
That's why when you wake up in the morning, I suggest you to flip the off switch on the right machine itself, just to turn it off, allow it to cool, that would be the only harm in it stayed on 24 seven isn't going to get hot.
But if you have air circulating around the machine, that isn't really an issue at all either.
We do have multiple patients that are running at 24 seven.
We have some people in the hospital and since they're late in the hospital bit all day there they've been running the right 24 seven there's no harm in there.
The only harm would be as if you don't have proper you don't have proper circulation and it's just that machine itself is heated up.
There isn't any harm in the bulb unless you actually have the bulb like you don't wrap in a blanket or something it's not getting any air and that could heat up and damage the plastic a little bit on the outside but otherwise there isn't any problem.